[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
yay
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now
so
that's what i'm talking about
no check this out
[Music]
foreign
that's what i'm talking about
[Music]
go check this out
[Music]
thanks
[Music]
done
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
what
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
swinging again
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
bye
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
never
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
yay
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
hi i'm amit catwalla from wide magazine
and welcome to spotlight
this is the last episode in the ea
series that connects you to the games
you love
and the people who make them leading up
to ea play live on july 22nd ei have
invited me to the discussion about fifa
22
we're going to be talking about the next
gen tack that they're using to make
football even more realistic
what a game we have in store for you
today the hype has been building
all week and the fans are pouring into
the stadium the tension
palpable stay with us we'll have all the
action for you live right here
on ea tv we've got a great panel of
developers from fifa here to join us
today
please introduce yourselves and your
history of fifa hi everyone i'm sam
riveda i'm the lead gameplay producer
and i've been at ea for 12 years
i can tell you i'm a very passionate
fifa player i
obviously play the game a lot at work
but also for fun at home
and probably my biggest achievement in
fought was to reach division one
in rivals however i got relegated it
didn't last for too long
but still it's something that i enjoy a
lot just playing the game and hi
i am shawn pedrick i'm a gameplay
producer also on fifa
i've been working at ea for and on fifa
for just over nine years now
before i joined ea and when i was
younger and much fitter i was a
professional football player
in england wales and north america
so i'm very passionate about football
and obviously fifa so again like
everybody here i'm super excited to talk
to you about gameplay in fifa 22 today
i'm kancho dasgov the gameplay director
for fifa 22.
i've been at ea for 14 years and i
absolutely love football
aside from that i'm really into the
skillful side of things one of my side
hobbies is called freestyle football
so i love juggling the ball doing all
sorts of tricks i've worked on all of
the skills in the game that's one of my
biggest passions hi i'm gabe zarrow
i'm the community manager global
engagement
for fifa and i come originally from
brazil
so football is kind of i come originally
from brazil
so football is kind of a religion for us
i
played fifa for most of my life and i
can say that my biggest achievement on
fifa 21 was to get
elite three uh also division one really
really great to meet you all
now i think like all of you i've been
playing fifa for most of my life and i
was really excited for the next gen
version
to come out when i reviewed fifa 21
there was a lot of
room to grow within the game in the next
gen so i'm really interested to hear
about the work you guys have been doing
to improve the game year on year
and how next gen tech is changing fifa
22.
now one of the big changes that you've
made for fifa 22 on next gen is
high promotion which is going to make
football and fifa feel way more
realistic but
can you tell me a bit about it what
exactly is high formation sound
hypermotion is a nexian exclusive
technology
powered by real football that brings
gameplay to the next level of realism
high promotion integrates advanced 11 vs
11 mocap
and machine learning for the first time
to create the most authentic
responsive and fluid experience on the
pitch so what does that mean exactly
what
what's this 11v11 mocap you're talking
about and and how does machine learning
kind of come into that
in the past we used to capture animation
in a mock-up studio through an optical
way of doing it
and we used to have maybe one two three
players and we would tell them go to
this direction
kick the ball in this direction so
advance 11 versus 11 motion capture
excellent suits allows us to for the
first time capture
22 professional footballers playing on
the pitch
in other words the data from these
players in the real football environment
it's where it's powering
the motion of players and teams in fifa
22.
so what does the algorithm the machine
lagging algorithm do with all that data
how does it
take all that data from that match and
all the other data that you have and
apply it to
the animations that are used in fifa 22.
our cutting-edge and proprietary machine
learning algorithm
learns from over 8.7 million frames
from the advanced 11 versus 11 mod cap
and then in real
time creates animation this animation
creates more
organic and fluid motion in a different
set of scenarios in the game so what
you're gonna see is players alternating
between different like let's say a short
step and then a longer step to properly
get into the position where he can kick
the ball
for either a pass or shot or just a ball
control
and that just makes things look and feel
more like football
motion is more fluid because players in
real life they
adjust their cadence they look at the
ball they position their bodies
to get there to get to the ball and
that's what you see with this new
machine learning technology that we have
in the game in fifa 22.
can you tell me a bit more about this
mattress 11v11 match because i think
we've all seen or fifa fans would have
seen videos of players doing motion
capture in those suits with the little
white dots on them but this was a full
game of football with all 22 players
wearing these suits right
so i remember you telling us a story
about the 11b11 in spain right like you
were hyping up the players
you were telling them go really hard
this is your chance to be in the game
and and what happened there that was a
very important part uh we told them look
this is the first time we're putting
people actually playing this for
professional players playing football
and this animation is going to the game
so go and try hard
and exactly at the end of the of the
game they were about to fight
uh it was it was very interesting but we
really got the data that we wanted you
see
that the data is more athletic now
there's more intensity
physicality is there and also a lot of
behaviors that you don't usually get
with regular motion capture
players being more human you get to take
all these
behaviors and talking and pointing
directing people
you get all these little things uh all
these football behaviors now we have
them and we can put them
in the game which makes a more authentic
uh version of fifa and the other thing i
noticed was the emotion
there was a play i saw where the player
the player didn't get the ball and he
could tell he was so frustrated like why
didn't you pass the ball to me
and that was so natural just that the
way he did that emotion
so we put that into the game that's
crazy
when you have one person in the studio
so many
cameras on this one person it's it's
hard to be as natural
as with 22 people in one pitch right so
exactly so this is really changing how
we capture animation in football
and it's taking it to the next level
yeah i think another little component
that
the country has touched on but that i
see when i when i looked at this xs data
was
just the natural behaviors that the gabe
was touching on the physicality
that you couldn't get in the mocap shoot
that's more structured now
we see players just naturally falling
over each other just
sounds so simple but it's actually quite
hard to to direct and
say just fall over that you need to put
it in a real environment
and see the players just come together
naturally and make these fall so
that's just one part of it but like
there's so much more that we we can
gather from this sex end zeta which
which really elevates the game
so it sounds like these new next-gen
consoles have really opened up the
ability to use
machine learning and use these new
technologies to make the game
more realistic cancer can you tell me a
bit more about the 11v11 game and what
exactly motion capture is adding to fifa
22 here
yeah so the data captured from this
advanced 11v11 mocap shoot
actually has resulted in over 4 000 new
animations added to the game
and just to give you an idea that's
three times more animations than we
added last year
so this is a huge huge animation refresh
these animations show off the
footballing intensity the athleticism
the physicality of professional players
and this results
in a huge improvement in player motion
so this is a fundamental leap forward in
the way players move and
act and behave in the on the field you
know from your perspective as someone
who loves that skills-based approach and
loves the feeling of real football but
how does it actually make the game feel
different does the game feel more
responsive is it smoother
the game just looks more like football
than ever before players really feel
like professional footballers in the
game now
can you give me an example of what you
mean when you talk about animations
is this something like a player playing
a pass or a player making a tackle or
are they smaller than that is it smaller
actions or is it these kind of big
actions or both
so it's it's individual actions such as
a player switching the ball from one
side of the field to the other
doing that type of lofted pass just the
motion to slice underneath the ball with
your foot
the way professionals do it it's it's
quite unique
just to see that motion play out and and
follow the ball
as it's flying through the air so these
kind of moments in the game really make
the game
make it feel more football because you
have the professional players actually
doing these actions
in a match will that differ depending on
how good the player is like
will lionel messi approach the ball
differently to a league two player or
you know
a player from a lower division in fifa
there's definitely some personality in
terms of how we calculate how
well the player can get into well how
fast there's multiple systems that
combine
to give you that fluidity messi will be
a little bit faster to get to the ball
however here is more not necessarily
about the personality it's just about
knowing how you need to get to the ball
so when you put all the systems together
then yes players like messi players like
ronaldo they have a better sense of how
to
shield how to position their body so it
can you can get away from the defender
obviously football isn't just about
individuals right it's also about teams
and tactics and there's
new features called team intelligence so
we're adding more team intelligence to
fifa 22.
sean can you tell me a bit more about
that please it's driven by the power of
the new generation of consoles
tactical ai creates deeper intelligence
for all 22 players on the pitch
this starts with the attacking side of
things now in the attack
each of these players can have up to six
times more decisions per second
than ever before so now the attacking
runs are much more intelligent and also
the build-up play in the chance creation
the players make much more supported
runs which improves the level of
tactics also the defensive side of
things is a big improvement too for
for tactical ai this was completely
rewritten this year
so now the defensive side of positioning
team do more zonal marking and defend as
a unit
it looks like a real game on when you're
watching it on tv like
teams nowadays play very tactical very
structured formation so
we wanted to get that feeling across
into into fifa 22.
you always tell me keep your shape keep
your shape don't get out of position
even when we're playing together right
yeah that's the most important thing
that's what i noticed in fifa 22.
like you see the the teams defensively
they move together as the ball
moves from one side of the field to the
other the defense moves together
yeah it's a big part of football
nowadays right he said like
work in previous fifa's maybe they would
work in twos and threes defending
whereas you really want the team to work
together and be more
zonal and and defend as a unit so so
yeah now you feel this straight away
when you when you boot up the game for
the first time in this example
shows the defensive rewrite of the
system
you can see the back four working um as
a in
a unit and as a zonal marking to really
work together from
when the ball switches from one side of
the pitch to the other side they shift
together as a team to really
work as a unit and defend that space we
analyze a lot of
professional football just to see how
teams
retain their shape when they are
defending when they move up the field
and that's what you are seeing in in the
game now which is
just gives you that feeling of more
authentic experience and actually in
fifa 22
you can tweak your attacking tactics so
they're different depending on
whereabouts on the pitch you are right
sean
yeah of course yeah you kind of nailed
it with that one in the attacking
tactics you can
set your tactics in both chance creation
and build up play
which in other words means that if you
have the ball in your defensive half of
the pitch you can set your tactics to
play one way
possession football for example but then
when you play the attacking side of the
pitch you can change to completely
different tactics so
gives the user and everyone more control
to adjust your tactics and customize how
you want to play
this is a very important feature
especially for those that play
competitively because you get more
control you can as you said pick your
tactics differently and
it's going to be an important one so
tactics is one thing and you know we've
all watched champions league finals
where it's like a chess game but we've
also all watched you know or at least
i've watched a lot of league two
football where it's more like a
wrestling match
how does hypermotion improve the
physicality of players we've added
the new kinetic air battles so now when
the ball's in the air
you see the differences where two
players are synced together
so the visuals of two players going up
for the header look
way better than it ever has but also
maintaining the responsiveness of
what the user wants because you really
need to focus on the responsiveness as
well as the visuals so
these two things combine really elevates
the in airplay battles
in fifa 22. yeah and the thing about the
new headers right it's we're using the
two-player interaction technology
so now as you said we're syncing up two
players going up for the ball so when
they collide it actually looks really
natural the way they stumble or fall
after that collision it's not like
individual
objects hitting each other this is like
two players really going up and battling
for the ball
so two players could be running side by
side jumping up for the ball they could
be back-handling one guy could be
running
in a certain direction the other guy in
the opposite direction but the point is
that they go up together you're gonna
feel that physicality now
there's a bunch of different areas of
fifa that are being touched by this
hypermotion technology and another one
cancer is ball control which has really
benefited from these extra animations
player's first touch is so important in
today's modern game
and high promotion gives us such a huge
animation refresh that now
we're able to control the ball more
fluidly than ever before
and the way we're doing that is by
adding new multi-touch animations and
that's the key
these animations are longer and they
have multiple touches
which allows you to bring down a ball
off the chest and onto your foot
in one fluid motion so with the longer
animations you're able to take the ball
off your thigh
cushion it and turn quickly away from
your opponent you're gonna feel these
new animations especially in
controlling air balls so anytime the
balls in the air are bouncing
you're gonna take that quick touch off
your thigh or off your chest turn
fluidly with that second touch into into
the direction that you want to go in
we're calling this feature composed ball
control because the players are
way more natural at taking that first
touch and transitioning to the second
one look at the very start of this clip
you can see um a multi-touch trap if i'm
not mistaken where he's shielding the
defender
comes off his thigh it lands nicely in
front of him to then
move forward and yeah that that part to
me uh looks
looks looks great yeah yeah and the
thing is it's not just the visual
improvement it actually
allows the players to control the ball
quicker so one touch off the chest
setting it up for one touch on with the
foot and that's it you're off
it's not like in previous fifa's where
sometimes you take the ball off the
chest
it bounces awkwardly and you have to
like adjust it's way more responsive now
because it's literally
one touch to touch and you're off that's
so important right because in on a
competitive level
on fifa you see that the best players
they're just trying to adjust for the
best
shot or the best pass yeah and like in
professional
footballers also as well as kind of
saying the realism in fifa
from an authentic point of view it's all
about the first touch like when you
coached as a kid or up until whatever
level you play at
always focus on the first touch getting
the ball out of your feet
one two touches and then you're away and
having all of these additional
animations there's over 400 new
animations for controlling the ball
just due to high promotion and this is
this is just bringing a whole new level
of realism to the game that allow
players to turn
quickly away from their opponents and
just to add to that in the past we used
to prioritize
shorter animations to keep the game as
responsive as possible
however now this technology as cancer
mentioned allows us to
have longer animations with more than
one touch on each animation which
results in better visual quality
but we still have that ability to
transition out of that animation at any
time into something else if the
situation changes let's say there's a
defender coming
and in the middle of a trap that is very
long i need to go in a different
direction and we can transition out
so now we have the best of both worlds
responsiveness and good visuals
in the game and i just have to say that
out of all of the new animations in the
game that we got from high promotion
these are the ones that really stand out
to me
one of the other things that really
makes the game feel like real football
is the stuff that goes on off the ball
you know you've made real efforts to
humanize the players and to make them
not just stand there like mannequins
when they're not doing anything but to
look and behave and act like real
players would on the pitch
so when we analyzed the 11b11 advanced
mocap we actually noticed the players
are communicating all the time
i'm saying man on go here i'm offering
support
all these things that professionals do
all the time every second during a game
communicating talking so there's a lot
of
new behaviors that we've added players
just gesturing to each other saying like
hey i was free for a pass why didn't you
pass it to me or
look i'm gonna go into this space pass
it to me there or
look watch out who's behind you uh these
are just some examples of the behaviors
that
we're adding to the game and some of
them are super subtle you may not pick
them up but you're kind of you're gonna
get this general sense that players are
more alive
you know where you're gonna notice the
most uh during set pieces like
you have a goal kick you have a throw
and players are
talking communicating asking for the
ball and they actually move a little bit
to provide you
with better support so you will have
more passing options in those
deep free kicks for example uh but it's
all about this
uh objective of making players more
human and just smarter
across the pitch we hear from feedback a
lot that
you know we have a parcel of our player
base that talks about
these animations so much because they
are playing for an immersive
experience the career mode guys for
example they go wild with these types of
things
it's incredible like the reception you
know for these
small pieces of animations that just
create a more immersive experience for
those players it's
it's huge for them and the other thing
you'll notice about this clip is the way
holland runs we have a star specific
locomotion for uh early highland he is a
big time player he's a young
superstar and the way he runs is so
unique he's kind of got this like a
little bit of a hunch in his posture and
big strides so to represent that power
and uniqueness of his running style
we've got
his his uh his running style in the game
now and the beautiful part of this is
their upper body layer animations
meaning
they don't hinder responsiveness you can
do whatever you want on the controller
these are just layers on top and also to
add a little bit extra from my
experience when
this thing came into the game when we
played it a couple of weeks ago it
actually makes you think about the game
and play it a little bit differently
because
because now i might see a player off the
ball calling for the ball i'm like oh
maybe i should like think about passing
to this guy or
you know it just changes the way you
think and play the game a little bit
because you see these off-ball players
doing these gestures and
and being more football so all this
combined just
just elevates the way you play play fifa
and gameplay yeah so the animations
actually go to pretty much every area of
the game you see goalkeeper you see
the two-player headers you see passes
shots
ball control pretty much everywhere all
these
humanization gestures we are putting
those animations from the mock-up shoot
in uh every area of the game basically
that's so so fascinating one of the
things i remember
from writing about this in the past is
that the best midfield players move
their heads around
much much more than kind of average
midfield players if you measure how much
javi
or frank manpod or steven gerrard or a
more modern midfield player
moves their head around when they're
when they're on the pitch
and it's really interesting how this
kind of in real football this
upper body movement actually has a
direct correlation to how good a player
is and how many passes they place it's
really great to see that being reflected
in
fifa 22 as well now we've talked about
high promotion and how it changes
how did it changes play but there's some
other developments in fifa 22 as well
and i'm just going to ask each of you to
name a couple of things that you're
excited about and excited to bring to
the fans in fifa 20 when it comes out
sean maybe you can go first yeah one of
the biggest things
that we haven't talked about yet is the
new goalkeeper system
this new system unlocks much more
reliable
saves for the goalkeeper as well as
making smarter decisions
in vital moments in the game to be
honest that was the first thing i
noticed when playing fifa 22. it was
like i was playing i was like okay
i understand this is cool but when the
the ball went to the goalkeeper
he did a completely new animation it
just stood out because
i'm so used to as a core player i'm so
used to the
regular animations until fifa 21 and
then the first time he came out i was
like
wait what what's he doing it was really
suit up yeah of course
for the animations we've completely
added a bunch of new animations to
refresh how the keeper looks as gabe was
saying so
yeah and it's not just the animations
right the tech we're using to you know
you know to play back those animations
has been upgraded so as gabe mentioned
the first thing you notice is like oh my
god that was so much more fluid than
last year's game yeah even just the
small details about the way the
goalkeeper follows the ball as it passes
his hand
that's all much more realistic than it
was before so
not only the full-body animation of the
goalkeeper flying through the air but
the way his head is tracking the ball as
it
flies into the net country what are some
of the examples of things that people
might
not notice at first glance which appear
when you take a closer look
there's actually a lot of subtle
animations that have gone into the game
such as
the way you lay the ball off for the
first time pass to
even just doing a driven pass like one
of those daisy cutters you know where
you
when you drive the ball low and hard
across the field so you kind of notice
these
these new ways to kick the ball and
that's all coming from that 11b11
competitive
motion capture shoot that we did we're
calling this feature full team authentic
motion
because it's all about all those little
bits of animation that we're sprinkling
into the game
thousands and thousands of it and it
just brings the characters
more to life i'm amazed by the depth you
guys have gone to as well because it's
not just the player animations that have
been refreshed but you've really kind of
reworked the way the actual ball works
right
yeah that's actually a big one it's a
game-changing feature
so what we're doing in fifa 22 is we're
importing
real-world ball data into the game
to create the next level of realism in
terms of how the ball
moves so we are changing parameters like
the friction on the ground the friction
with the air
just how the ball spins the speed of the
ball
and that really changes the perception
of the game how the ball moves it's a
lot
more authentic and you notice that right
away
for example if you do a pass a love pass
to switch the field
the hang time of the ball is now more
obvious and really
so satisfying to do one of those uh love
passes across the field and so again to
put it in context you do the pass you
see a brand new animation from the
mock-up
11 versus 11 that we did then the ball
flies in a completely different way that
is more authentic
and then when the player is receiving
the ball those new long animations play
and that changes experience completely
yeah even just passing the ball around
simple ground passes to your teammates
they don't slow down as much now right
so you can
pass the ball turn past the ball turn
you're not like waiting for it to get to
you so
that just improves sort of the flow of
the game i found yep
definitely but if you do find yourself
you know one-on-one with an opponent and
everything slowed down and you're kind
of faced up
against them there's a new way of
getting past them on fifa 22 right
there's a mechanic called explosive
sprint when you press that right trigger
at the right time you're going to get a
bigger push
and acceleration with the ball now this
works both on dribbling and defending
so if you're trying to catch up to a
dribbler who maybe got a step on you
you're going to get that boost while
while just running and sprinting
but if you're a dribbler you can really
lure that opponent in to get close
and get by him with a with a quick
acceleration that changes the way
you you defend and attack you've got to
really think about now
when you you press that sprint button
you get the benefits of waiting and
trying to have these mini games between
the attacker and the defender
to to really time these these inputs to
to see this explosion of sprint and both
defenses and attacking side of things so
and one of the biggest questions around
this feature is is it going to make the
game now
op the sprinting part of the game uh but
no that's exactly what we are tuning we
are making sure that
you feel that explosiveness but it's not
necessarily going to be the only way to
play so we're balancing things
considering
how players will be trying to use this
mechanic
yeah there is a cooldown you can't just
spam this mechanic
right so you can use it once but then if
you want to use it again you have to
wait some time
exactly i think we could talk about this
all day but i'd love to find out a bit
more about how you guys listen to the
fans
and the process that your dev team
undergoes to deliver on the feedback
that you guys get
we have a huge player base with millions
and millions of players around the world
and it's it's a lot of different
priorities from these different types of
players
so we have different platforms and
initiatives
uh to take care of that feedback so for
example the game changer network we talk
directly to influencers content creators
and feedback specialists we have the
fifa community design council which is a
group that is completely focused on
getting feedback early on the
development stages of the game
we have pro players being part of that
console we have
content creators that are focused on
foot we have people that are completely
focused on career mode
we have a couple of casuals and we have
you know
the average fifa player which could fall
into different categories
as well the idea there is for us to give
them as much information
as early as possible so that they can
interact directly with the producers
and actually give some feedback before
we go into
the depths of development sam can you
tell me a bit about what it's like
working with the feedback that you get
from the fans via gabe after listening
to all the
ideas from the fans all the feedback we
also look at data for example and we
know a lot of things about the health of
the game we call it
how many goals are scored per game in
average how many files how many offsides
how many shots
we can see in a detailed diagram
basically where all the shots coming
from what's the
success rate for each different type of
shot and we analyze all this information
to try to make the best decisions
we also play the game a lot obviously
we're producers as part of our job
and that's very important to really
understand what are those frustrations
so let me get this straight so if
players are complaining about
it being too easy to score from crosses
or too difficult to score from headers
you can see that in the data
we can and we also set targets sometimes
based on how we want the game to play
so if we think there's too many goals
from crosses and we feel like maybe
there's not enough skill needed to score
on a cross because you just need to go
to the wing and then
cross it then we try to design systems
to sign the game maybe in a two-player
header situation how can we get uh the
best outcome
that that creates a balanced game how
much does the game change from you know
the first release to
by the time the next game comes out and
how quickly
players kind of find the easy ways to
score you know is it within a week of
release is it within a day of release
where you see oh actually there's too
many goals being scored from crosses or
too many goals being scored from headers
a lot of the bugs that we find require
millions of players
competing online so sometimes it takes
months for the community to really
discover certain things in the game
and we are we're there we're playing
every weekend we are monitoring and we
are talking to people to get the
feedback right away and act right away
that's really fascinating stuff it's so
great to hear about how you guys are
reacting to feedback all right that's
just about all we've got time for but
this has been so so fascinating thank
you so much to the guy from fifa for
answering our questions
and thank you to the fans for watching
in and listening before we go gabe's got
a few
dates for your diary to look out for if
you're interested in more about fifa 22
yeah for sure so make sure to stay tuned
as we will be releasing a lot of
different pitch notes articles that have
deep dives on
game play and all of the modes that we
have on fifa 22
and make sure to check out our top bins
streams that happen every friday on our
twitch channel
where we will have these guys as guests
we will have art directors uh all sorts
of
good people that work on the game to let
you
get more information and the inside
scoop on
everything fifa 22 related can i add
something gabe yes please
definitely check out the gameplay pitch
notes there's a lot of features that we
don't get to cover here in this
interview but there's a lot of depth a
lot of those features are coming
directly from the feedback from the
community
and we're trying to create the best
experience for everyone all right
that's it for the spotlight series for
more information check out ea.com and
make sure to follow ea on twitter and
you won't want to miss ea play live at
10 a.m pst
on july 22nd for more about fifa 22.
i've been amit catwalla from wired and
this has been spotlight thank you so
much for watching
[Music]
you